Humdrum. Boring. This meeting
should have been an email. Dry.
When can we leave? Phrases like
this, right? Ideally, don't come up
or are not used to describe a gathering or
conversation. In this video, we're gonna unpack
how to create humor in conversation? I really love
to laugh. If you're not good at humor or you don't
identify as a funny person you'll love this video.
If you are a humorous person and you are a funny
person you'll love this video. Because I'm going to
unpack the science behind it. If you hate humor and
think it doesn't have a place in conversation
or work or life, don't watch this video, please.
I'm Chad Littlefield, I'm the co-founder of We
and Me and the creator of this connection toolkit
and one core aspect to connection is humor.
It's one of the ways that we relate. Let's get into it.
They say that laughter is the best medicine.
Is that the phrase actually? Okay, well, I'll just
google it. I'm not really sure if they say that
laughter is the best medicine. But I'm saying
right now that laughter is great medicine and in
this video, I'm going to share comedian secrets
on how to create some humor and also the
science and art behind humor. Robert Provine
at the University of Maryland found with
his research team that people tend to laugh
30 times more when they are with people
than when they are alone and for me this is
points toward the importance of humor in
connection. We tend to laugh with you.
Now, there are lots of reasons for that and
alsolaughter is not synonymous with humor.
You can think something's really funny and be deadpan
and not laugh you can also laugh and not think
something is funny. One of my teacher's Jeff Falls
used to say that laughter is nervousness leaving
the body and since he said that I cannot
stop thinking about that. Every time somebody
laughs I'm like, are you nervous or you actually
think that was funny, right? So, I think there's
different types of laughter. I've cometo
understand that there are different types
of laughter. But oftentimes, laughter with
peopleis like a nervous chuckle. Even if
it's boisterous laughter it helps fill that
awkwardness. I just got back from a little
mini family reunion with some family I haven't
seen in many years and there was a ton of laughter.
Most of it was very genuine like happy to be
back together with each other. Some of it was like,
we haven't seen each other for a while and so
let's just like say something goofy everybody
laughs and it releases this tension. It's like
nervousness leaving or if it's nervousness
leaving the body. It's tension leaving a group.
The second piece of the science of humor is I wish
that I could find the source. I tried really hard
before hitting record. But I was reading a book
that was about comedy and about the science behind
comedy and in it they had a graph and I have not
been able to find this graph. So I don't even
knowif this is rooted in data or not. But the visual
was extremely useful to help me understand
whathumor actually is. If you picture just a simple
y-axis and x-axis. The graph of humor
that was in this book that I can't remember
went like this. I did find some science on it.
I'll share some ridiculously academic language with you.
But it's essentially humor is where something is
going one trajectory. So, picture a line going like
this and you expect that line to continue.
Because the brain the human brain wants to
extrapolate what's happening next. So saying,
"Okay, this is where we're going this way...
We're probably going to go this way
and humor and laughter happens
when the story doesn't go that way. It takes a turn
for something different. The research that I found
on this. So, you get the idea, right? You probably
don't need any more than that to understand that
humor is when we think something's going one
way and it doesn't. I have a really fun example
to share with you. But the academic language
of humor is the juxtaposition of incompatible
concepts. It's like, okay, right. Two things don't go
together and you put them together in a way and
it was surprising and that created some humor
or laughter. One really concrete example that
I've been trying to master lately are dad jokes.
So, what is the leading cause of dry skin?
Towels. This is like a terrible joke but it was
not the answer you expected. Now, with that one
like you might not have expected any answer.
But you were probably thinking about like some skin
disorder or like dry temperatures or something
else. You weren't thinking about... What was
funny about that was the fact that you weren't
expecting something so obvious and literal.
If you've ever come across anti-jokes before this
is a perfect example of how the trajectory of
something is going one way and then it takes a
deep-dive turn for something else. So, for example,
What's worse than finding a whole worm in your
apple? Breaking your leg. It's like yes, okay. What's
worse than finding a whole worm in your apple is
of course, if I'm extrapolating it's finding a half
of a worm in your apple. But when you go anti-jokes
the idea that you're something so incompatible and
juxtaposed that it's popped in and now a caveat
with this. Some people find anti-jokes funny some
people do not. I've learned that. I happen
to be somebody who appreciates anti-jokes
feel free to leave one in the comments if you want
to make me laugh. The third way and maybe the more
practical way this can show up in conversation is
through story. So, if you're subscribed to the cha...
If you're subscribed to the cha... If you're subscribed
to the channel. You may have heard me share the
story about the girl with tattoos all over her
neck and in that story you expect that
story to go one way and when it doesn't and
I have told this story to many thousands
of people in person in live audiences o remote
audiences and every single time it creates
quite a whole heap of laughter and the reason
is that story takes a turn that people weren't
expecting. It also happens to be at my expense too.
Which probably starts to dip into the art of humor.
Some of the stuff that's not necessarily rooted in
data or science that we don't totally understand
but we know contributes to something being funny
or humorous. Which speaking of, let's shift gears
completely into the art of humor. The first thing
is energy. This used to really frustrate me. But
the most common feedback that I would get after
leading a workshop giving a keynote or even just
a one-on-one mentoring or coaching call with a
client. Almost every single time somebody would
come up to me and say, "Oh, Chad, I love yourenergy",
and they used to frustrate me. Because I was
like, what do I do with that feedback? Like,
I don't know what that is and then I realized
that is an essential element to why people laugh
at a story that I tell or why people are really
present when I lower my voice. It's my energy is
eeking out of my pores I can't help it. Maybe much
to my wife's dismay at five in the morning when
I wake up and I'm feeling energy for life. Now, I
don't wake up every morning at 5am feeling
likethat. But the point is your energy is it's not
something that we've scientifically been able to
point at. Energy's a little bit of an ethereal world
but you know it matters. I met my wife
living on an Anishinabe Indian reservation in
northern Minnesota on this trip for a month
and there were these two medicine men. One of
the names Richard Morrison and he walked into
the room and I've got a little bit of ADD, ADHD.
He walked in the room and whatever
energy brought in with him was just...
I was brought down to the ground and I sat
still and listened for four hours straight
as he talked. He just had this energy that just
commanded a presence in aroma change the dynamic.
Some people have that energy that contributes
to humor. So, again, it's the art. I don't have a
specific tip or directive here other than
to tune into what energy you're giving off.
If you're giving off an all business monotone
energy no one's gonna laugh when you make a joke.
Unless you're in Britain maybe. The secondnote
on the art of humor is around sarcasm. Will, my
co-founder introduced me to the idea that sarcasm
in the original Greek actually means to tear flesh
and I need to fact-check everything. So, of course,
I fact check that and it actually means to
tear flesh like a dog and so as somebody who tends
to be drawn towards sarcasm. It's really forced
some introspection for me of how useful that is
for people versus when it's at somebody else's
expense versus when I could create humor through
another pathway. If somebody comes up to me and I
sarcastically say, "Oh, you look really nice today or
oh, nice hair." I am tearing them apart in that
and it's just hidden with this culturally
acceptable thing we call sarcasm and so part
of the art of humor is being really mindful.
Will takes a stance, he says, no sarcasm.
I don't take such a hard stance. I think sarcasm
is fine. If it serves a purpose and is at nobody
else's expense or even if it's a little bit
self-deprecating I'm cool with that too. I think
the best way to alienate yourself from a group or
a conversation or an audience is to put yourself
on a pedestal, someone who always succeeds makes it
everything works out just fine. As opposed to being
like oh my goodness, you have no idea there's
like stumbling through the world failure after
failure learning some things as we go. Okay, last
bit combining the art and science of humor and
I'm really really excited about this one. I want to
get better at humor and so I would love for you to
comment below with what you think creates humor in
a conversation. In theory, the longer this video is
on the internet the more useful the comment
thread will get. I'm Chad Littlefield, I hope
this helped you as a leader or an educator make
connection engagement easy. Have an awesome day.